we're going to show you how Google Cloud
offers a modern approach to database
management to remove risk and unlock
your organization's productivity and
speed of innovation to drive a digital
transformation
digital transformation starts with
modern apps which are powered by
operational databases modern
applications have significantly
different requirements than Legacy ones
since they have a much larger user base
have a global presence and have higher
user expectations in terms of
performance and availability
in our demo today you will see our Cloud
database platform in action solving the
hardest challenges for a digital
transformation
our customers journey to digital
transformation is often a three-step
process migrate modernize and transform
in this demo we'll be covering the first
two migrate for Enterprises to lift and
shift their current databases to
compatible managed services such as
Cloud SQL and modernize Legacy databases
to a modern Cloud database such as alloy
DB
our demo company symbol bank is a
fictitious National financial
institution serving millions of
customers with its banking services
we're speaking with their VP of it
Aditya Aditya and his team used to
self-manage their databases and realize
that it is complex costly and time
consuming they had to continuously
allocate scarce people resources to
provision configure secure patch
maintain and monitor their databases
with self-management they had to set up
database authentication data encryption
and take several steps to reduce risk
and improve compliance in addition they
had to set up high availability
configure scaling with read replicas
manage continuous backups to protect
from data loss and orchestrate complex
And Timely database maintenance to
minimize application downtime
these cumbersome and complex tasks took
away from the time and focus to innovate
in their applications and better serve
their customers
symbol Bank adopted Cloud SQL to address
the above pain points of self-managed
databases Cloud SQL is a fully managed
relational database service for postgres
MySQL and SQL Server Cloud SQL offers
full compatibility with the underlying
database engine along with a common API
and management interface across these
engines
symbol bank's many services run on cloud
SQL because provisioning a database in
Cloud SQL takes minutes and can be done
with just a few clicks in the console
via the gcloud CLI tool with terraform
or via the web API
also Cloud SQL automatically increases
storage based on your application needs
connecting an app to Cloud SQL instances
is easy from any application because
Cloud SQL integrates with Google compute
engine Google kubernetes engine and
on-premise servers also bigqueries Cloud
SQL Federation enables bigquery to query
data residing in Cloud SQL in real time
without copying or moving data
backups and point-time Recovery are
automatically enabled for cloud SQL
instances to help protect from data loss
we can restore both on-demand or
automated backups to the same instance
where you took the backup another
instance in the same region or even to a
different region you can easily set up
up to 10 replicas of data across zones
for high availability with automatic
failover which is double or more than
that of the two other large Cloud
providers
Cloud SQL also provides industry-leading
maintenance times and granular control
over maintenance Windows allowing
flexibility to best support your
business
for example for MySQL and postgres Cloud
sql's average maintenance downtime is
shorter than that of Amazon RDS and
Azure database according to figures
published in online documentation as of
August 2021
symbol Bank relies on Google Cloud
databases because they're built on a
globally trusted and secure platform
they provide best-in-class security to
protect systems with five layers of data
protection and help you meet stringent
data and security regulations identity
and access management or IAM integration
gives full control and visibility to
manage authentication and protect
against unauthorized access additional
features like VPC service controls audit
logging access transparency customer
manage encryption Keys integration with
security Command Center data residency
controls Etc help improve security
auditability and compliance
Cloud SQL cost recommenders are powered
by Machine learning algorithms and help
detect idle instances right size over
provisioned instances and leverage
committed use discounts cost
recommenders automatically generate
actionable reports that identify areas
where cost savings are possible
Cloud SQL query insights provides
monitoring and Diagnostics that help to
detect and fix query performance
problems traditional monitoring tools
provide a query-centric view of
performance this limitation can create a
disconnect between database and
application code especially with modern
architectures like microservices
Cloud SQL insights provides developers
with database monitoring through the
lens of the application
developers can use tags to associate
queries with specific business functions
such as payments and business Analytics
query insights supports open Telemetry
standards and makes the query metrics
and traces data available through the
Google Cloud's operations Suite API
query insights integrates Cloud
monitoring to create custom dashboards
and alerts on query metrics or tags and
to send notifications using email SMS
slack pagerduty and more
simple bank migrated to Cloud SQL using
database migration service which is
secure serverless and easy to use they
started migrating in just a few clicks
with a single integrated migration
experience the guided experience of
database migration service took them
through the source configuration
information and setup of network
connectivity for easy execution
the serverless experience of database
migration service eliminated operational
burden as there were no migration
servers to provision manage or Monitor
and auto scaling ensured high
performance and uninterrupted data
replication at scale database migration
service is so easy to use that 85
percent of all migrations using it are
underway in less than an hour
as we've shown you today Cloud SQL
automates and streamlines complex
database management tasks to reduce your
toil and to improve the availability
performance scalability security and
governance of your databases
as part of a new strategic initiative
symbol Bank expanded into the investment
business by offering customers a unified
experience for both their Banking and
investment account management
simple bank wanted to modernize from
Legacy proprietary databases to open
source compatible databases in the cloud
this required a database with even
higher performance availability
manageability and real-time analytic
capabilities they decided to standardize
on postgres because of its portability
Rich functionality extensibility
Enterprise features proven track record
and strong community
Elena the head of digital banking at
symbol is responsible for their
expansion into the investment business
increasing trade volumes and high Market
volatility are creating significant
technology challenges in online trading
simple bank has an opportunity to create
new customer facing experiences and
value if it could get real-time insights
via analytic queries at next level scale
and performance for the retail banking
clients in addition simple bank must be
able to process significantly large
numbers of requests per second while
simultaneously supporting thousands of
analytical queries from supporting
systems that must report on Trends and
aggregate key operational indicators
traditionally this hadn't been possible
through their data warehouse solution
because of the delay associated with
data movement and Transformations then
they implemented alloy DB to solve these
and other problems let's demo you today
what happened there
with loadb simple bank was able to
process transactional investment
operations such as stock and mutual
funds buy and sell orders for all of
their customers and at the same time
displayed real-time analytical
dashboards of all recent trading Trends
anomalies and key performance indicators
while this screen shows simple's
customer facing app the real Innovation
happened at the database underneath the
app it was powered by the hybrid
transactional and analytical processing
sometimes referred to as htap feature
and capability of alloy DB
alloy DB is more than two times faster
than Amazon's comparable postgres
compatible service for transactional
workloads loadb delivers up to 100 times
faster analytical queries than standard
postgres
htap inside ledb is created using two
critical features read replica pools and
a columnar engine combined they deliver
Lightning Fast performance this enables
the processing of multiple workloads
with the same durability consistency and
reliability of a traditional operational
database
here you can see how easy it is to add
read replica pools while maintaining the
performance even with the heavy h-tap
workloads
alloy DB is able to handle analytical
workloads on transactional data without
negatively impacting performance of
production systems as well as linearly
scale out read capacity in non-technical
terms that means your business can get a
whole lot of data analytical
capabilities to derive new insights and
business value it can truly unlock huge
future Innovations for your business and
customers
if you're interested in understanding
what really Powers our underlying
technical differentiation here's a quick
explainer powered by ml Driven Auto
population and management the columnar
engine automatically optimizes to the
application's access pattern delivering
blazing fast performance
in addition lodb uses adaptive machine
learning algorithms to automate database
optimizations such as automatic memory
management data storage tiering and
vacuuming
it does that and a whole lot more to
bring machine learning-led Innovations
and optimizations for our customers to
use in their databases
Elena's digital banking customers are
very happy to engage with our new
Services alloy DB with its htap
capabilities combined with Google scale
performance and availability is perfect
for running new hybrid workloads for
Enterprises also pricing for iodb is
transparent and predictable with no
expense or proprietary licensing and no
opaque i o charges
today we touched on the migrate and
modernized pillars of the digital
transformation Journey with Cloud SQL
and alloy DB stay tuned for upcoming
demos on spanner and bigtable and how
they can help your business create
transformative experiences with Planet
scale services
to help you get started we have a
database migration program with tooling
Technical Resources and financial
incentives to reduce the cost and effort
of your migration
thanks for watching